29th annual Motion Picture Academy of
Arts and Sciences Awards thank you very
much
what was this mystery voice and now to
present the awards for best art
direction and set decoration to death to
present the awards for art direction and
set Dec Direction decoration its fellows
that did a thing with a movie we present
two real champions Marge and Gower
champion
oh you know it's a nervous night how are
you nice to see you Gower and Marge
Marge and Gower what a mix-up this is I
want you to know that we're so very
happy that you kids have a show Sunday
night we're all gonna watch it on that
other Network the nominations for black
and white art direction and set
decoration the Magnificent Seven
Takashi you Matsuyama the proud and
profane art direction by hal pereira and
al Hedrick set decoration by Samuel M
comer and Frank our McKelvey the solid
gold Cadillac art direction by Ross
Bella set decoration by William R cannon
and Louie Diaz somebody up there likes
me art direction by Sedgwick Gibbons and
Malcolm F Brown set decoration by Edwin
B Willis and F killed Lisa and teenage
rebel our direction by Lyle our wheeler
and Jack Martin Smith set decoration by
Walter M Scott and Stuart a Reese the
envelope please you open it you stronger
you're really somebody up there likes me
the nominations for color art direction
and set decoration are around the world
in 80 days art direction by James W
Sullivan and Ken Adam set decoration by
Ross J Dowd giant art direction by Boris
Levin and set decoration by Ralph s
Hearst The King and I art direction by
Lyle our wheeler and John to cure set
decoration by Walter M Scott and Paul s
Fox lust for life art direction by
Cedric Gibbons hands Peters and Preston
aims and set decoration by Edwin B
Willis and FQ Gleason and the Ten
Commandments art direction by Walter H
Tyler and Albert nozaki and set
decoration by Samuel M Coomer and Roy or
Ray Moyer Ambler envelope envelope you
open cheerleader The King and I
thank you very much congratulations
gentlemen thank you Marge and Gower
champion I would like to say that Marge
and Gower were flown here by TWA
Trans World Airlines how does that
figure they live in Burbank what is this
a crazy thing